there is uh shockingly to some people a
debate going on about whether it's okay
or not to punch nazis and more broadly
the debate is about
when can you use force against political
enemies and there's one view
which is listen neo-nazi ideology is in
and of itself violent
so it's okay to be the initiator of
physical force to attack or
punch a nazi or anyone espousing nazi
ideology or even somebody just wearing a
nazi armband
on the other side of this the spectrum
is sort of a view of total pacifism
right
nazism is an idea if someone is
espousing that idea through speech or an
armband or whatever
it's totally inappropriate to initiate
force against them
and there's a little bit of overlap
there with the non-aggression principle
which is a common libertarian belief
it's not
pacifism but it's that one should never
be the initiator of force but if someone
else initiates force against you
it's okay to defend yourself now this
debate has come
up very acutely in the last 24 hours
because a neo-nazi was punched
and knocked unconscious with that one
punch yesterday in seattle
after being seen with a nazi armband on
the seattle d-line
subway he was later identified and
spotted elsewhere and quite simply he
was knocked out with a single punch so
i'm going to set up the situation for
you and then we'll discuss the
implications
a twitter account called bigotbasher
posted a picture of a man apparently
riding seattle's d-line
while wearing as you can see here a nazi
armband bigot basher wrote in their
tweet
that the man in the armband was
harassing a
black man on the bus now there's very
little information about who bigot
basher is and whether the allegation
about
harassing a black man on the bus is true
not much later
the same picture gets posted to the
seattle
subreddit and again there
is a sort of anti-fascist online
community
which based on this post that i'm
showing you tries to identify this
individual
and then the posts start coming in and
there's a post that says hey
we saw this guy at the intersection of
union street
and third avenue other twitter accounts
start to corroborate yeah
union street and third avenue and
minutes later
a facebook user whose real name is sean
patrick duff
shares this photo of what looks like the
exact same guy
lying unconscious on the ground with
other people looking on
there is video of the punch available
i'm not going to play it i don't think
it would add anything to the story
the man in the swastika armband can be
heard on the video
saying they deserve the welfare before
he's hit directly in the face by a guy
in a grey sweatshirt and subsequently
knocked unconscious
and immediately there's a whole bunch of
people who react to this
in the anti-fascist community
celebrating it absolutely loving it
the argument being made by people who
support the punching out of this guy
is listen he was harassing a black man
on the bus and this was merely a
response now
those against the punching out of this
guy say wait a second
we don't know if this guy was harassing
black people on the bus
the guy who did the punching certainly
wasn't one of the people on the bus who
could have witnessed that
and this is inappropriate violence now
of course this is against the law it's
not yet clear whether police are
involved in any way
i've been very clear about this issue i
do not believe it is okay
to punch nazis willy-nilly on a whim i'm
not saying this from some pie in the
sky the left should take the high road
type of position
i am saying i don't think it will
achieve anything
it might make neo-nazis scared to go out
in public wearing armbands
and that could maybe be seen as a
victory but from a pragmatic standpoint
it's not going to change the minds of
nazis to punch them in the face
if anything it's going to do the
opposite and it's going to be a feeding
frenzy for right-wing media for the
apologists to the so-called white
identity movement those who sympathize
with the ideology
we can have the moral debate and that
usually goes something like well
it's not okay to punch nazis because
they're not being physically violent and
then someone else says well
nazi ideology is violent so it's okay to
punch anyone who espouses it
the law happens not to agree with that
and the law is not always right
but i think the real problem here is the
pragmatic aspect of it this will not
achieve anything well i just think it's
completely counterproductive because you
take a guy like a neo-nazi
who obviously holds such deplorable
viewpoints and just about no one
sympathizing with him
and then you see him get punched out in
such a public way this video was put
online
and then just the national the natural
human emotion to respond to this is just
to express some sort of sympathy for him
we don't want him to be worthy of any of
our sympathy no let's not
make these individuals the victims and
from a practical perspective where do
you draw the line if nazi ideology is
violent enough for punching people in
the streets what about people who
advocate for the deportation of all
dreamers right kids who came to the u.s
underage and undocumented with their
parents that is major political violence
it is very violent
to send kids who came to the us through
no fault of their own back to a country
they may barely have a connection to
is it okay to punch people over that and
which people do we punch the politicians
who would vote in favor of that
or do we punch any random citizen who
supports the deportation of dreamers i
think it is very very problematic
and the bottom line is we don't aspire
to the same
values as nazis i don't anyway in
self-defense punch away
that has nothing to do with nazi views
anyone who's assaulting you
you are well within your rights to punch
away but
you have to take these arguments
sometimes to the extreme
to really understand why they don't make
sense and i actually read a comment
online saying hey
if no one punches nazis the holocaust
happens
that's a major slippery slope argument
right if i don't punch richard spencer
or this guy from seattle there's going
to be a holocaust we don't have to
resort to these tactics to achieve
social change period
and to be very clear i'm not in favor of
ignoring these people
you know that i've made it pretty clear
for a long time i don't subscribe to
that
but the movement to fight the resurgence
of neo-nazism or white supremacy
white separatism the white identity
movement call it what you want
it's not going to be toppled by
individuals who consider themselves
anti-fascist identifying an
armband-wearing dude
knocking him out and potentially getting
themselves arrested
it's just not going to be the right way
to approach this
the video you just watched was made
possible by support
from you please go to patreon.com
davidpakmanshow you can make a pledge of
as little as one dollar per month
and every dollar helps to support the
work that we're doing particularly in
light
of the youtube ad boycott which has been
really bad